what's up Flo Milly 251 to be exact I
actually well I can't say this so never
mind but somebody who looks like me
might be on the radio in Alabama soon oh
Lord somewhere but what radio I know
listen I have no idea actually because
it would I am not at Liberty to
currently say oh okay okay so you the
maybe one day there might be somebody
shortly who's similar to me on the radio
in Alabama interesting yeah Mobile
Alabama it's interesting because I've
driven through mhm cuz I used to live in
Tampa and so I've driven like from Tampa
to Arizona twice uh and back which is a
terrible drive it's like 36 hours it's
wild but you go up through like the
Panhandle yeah and then there's mobile
which is like at the bottom it's at the
bottom
yeah like I drove over a bridge y I
think I got Little Caesars there yeah
honestly the food in Mobile is the best
like is it the best yes I I will I'm
telling you that's the best like what
though like what is there the best of
there everything like when you if you
want to go get some breakfast food you
going to get the best breakfast there
I'm not even exaggerating like that's
how good it is just food period I know
we got like a lot of seafood and [__]
but I'm not like a big Seafood person
but the seafood that they do guys really
good do they got alligator nuggets I'm
sure they do Gator nuggets are fire yeah
they got everything y'all got Gators in
Mobile we do but it's not like as bad as
Florida like you ain't going to see the
[__] out on the street they're
outside I
remember you just pull this forward yeah
um living in Florida like alligators are
like a you know like they're kind of
like raccoons or like you know like
possums they're just there and they
might eat your Pomeranian if you leave
it outside to that's a crazy ass little
animal to have walking around with a
Pomeranian or an alligator an
alligator I have a pomeranian that's me
too for real his name's Labowski mine is
name Sosa wow what color is your
Pomeranian she's
like grayish blackish mine has a brown
head and a white body and he's like my
child he's a guy and he's like my
everything a I came home yesterday he
got excited and peed everywhere oh wow
oh he can't hand SE me for like a week
you know so he starts dancing and crying
and then I got to pick him up and he
pisses on me yeah because I be hearing
like dogs dog ears are different from
human years like a week to them is
probably like a year true because
they're they're like one year seven
years mhm so they like oh my God my
owner what and they don't know where
you're going to come back they don't got
phones they have no idea they might
think you'll be gone forever yeah they
might have already came to the
conclusion like dad's gone and he's
never coming back and then it's like and
then he sees you and then it's like it's
over I love it is that you only have one
dog yeah just one but I'm not even going
to like act like I be taking care of her
cuz I gave her to my mom so mom takes
care of the dog yeah what okay okay yeah
my mom well actually my mom got tired of
her and gave her to my aunt so now myt
damn so so your dog just getting passed
around like leftovers yeah but she's
like she don't don't feel bad for her
she's really bad like she's smart too
like she know what she be doing like she
be hiding stuff under the table one time
she got mad I left her at home chewed up
all my Louis Vuitton sneakers that's
when I was like all right you got to go
like you she's a che yeah especially
when she was teething like I got her
when she was like a baby so yeah and
then I started to like become famous I
couldn't it was hard for me to like take
care of her so I just gave her to my mom
and then my mom gave her to my aunt well
shout out to your auntie free dog a is
it a famous dog does it got an Instagram
no um actually she almost did get famous
but like I don't know it was why did she
almost how does a dog almost get famous
you have to walk me through this it's
kind of disturbing okay but she I
recorded her like humping this bear on
the floor and like it got like some
views on it but I was like okay I'm
going to take this down cuz she's
[__] shout out to the humping dogs
out there yeah my my Pomeranian will
hump my French Bulldog wait the
Pomeranian yes to like get it like my
Pomeranian hates my Frenchie so much
that when the Frenchie when the Frenchie
decides like like it's having fun
actively my my Pomeranian hates when my
other dog is happy sorry so he'll start
biting it and like trying to hump it to
get it to like go away and like what
it's the weirdest [__] ever that is
weird it's like a reality show with two
dogs at all times yeah it's crazy dogs I
don't know where they get that from